ben affleck and jennifer lopez continued
to double down on their rekindled
romance
and it just turned out to be something
really magical and this time it's by
making their holidays a family affair
here's what we know et has learned the
couple is planning to spend the holidays
with their children
this according to a source who explained
they want to be together all the time so
their next big things are thanksgiving
and christmas with the kids there's a
lot to coordinate so they are figuring
it out hey i'm ready i'm excited about
it the source added that affleck's x
jennifer garner only has positive vibes
about their relationship when ben is
happy and the kids are happy jen feels
like there's nothing she can be upset
about jen also says ben looks better
than ever she and ben are getting along
so well in a co-parenting sense and all
is good
affleck and garner share three children
violet seraphina and samuel while lopez
and ex-husband mark anthony are parents
to twins emmy and max they're so big and
so
amazing and happy lopez became engaged
to anthony following her and affleck's
initial breakup in 2004. and obviously
i'm not going to talk about anybody
else's personal life but uh
but i'm i'm very happy for her and i
hope she does great and how about this
for a full circle moment
while speaking with e.t at the time
affleck was also focusing on the
positives for his then ex and her new
man and i hope she's happy and i'm i i
know she's got a movie out i think this
weekend which is a great really good
movie and uh i hope that does real well
and uh eventually she'll probably have
an album come out and i hope that does
well so i wish her and mark the very
very best
now back in 2021 that karma appears to
be paying off for the reunited couple
the source also shared with et that
afflict and lopez could not be more in
love
it is like they never broke up but
everything is way better this time they
are all over each other and their
friends joke around about it with them
we're trying to get some can you see if
we can get in the papers because i'm
trying to get more listen and these new
details seem in sync with the couple's
pda this past week
the couple made their red carpet
comeback at the venice film festival for
the premiere of ben's new movie the last
duel they were seen laughing having
intimate combos doing all the
hand-holding and sharing a kiss it was
affleck and lopez's first movie premiere
appearance since 2003's gee lee
i think we have chemistry as actors from
the first moment we started working
this movie will always be important in a
landmark event in my life
[Music]
cut to the met gala monday night lopez
turned heads in a western inspired
ensemble and she also had everyone
asking
don't worry folks i want to give it away
but it has a very good ending
after jlo's solo appearance the couple
did reunite inside fashion's biggest
night of the year and they showed
everyone that masks are no masks benefit
2.0 is all about the pda
[Music]